[Music]
i have a story here
of a thief who ended up
he pretty much said that he was going to
call the cops
on the person he was stealing the car
from and the reason is
because once he he got it so this takes
place in oregon
he ends up getting inside of a car and
he starts
taking off with the car but he didn't
know that there was a four-year-old in
the back seat oh i saw this story so
then
once he realized once he realized that
there was a four-year-old little boy in
the back
he went back to the the shop that where
the mom was
and scolded her for leaving her kid
alone in the car as morals he was like
what the [ __ ] i'm gonna be calling the
cops on you lady don't ever leave your
kid
i'm a carjacker not a kidnapper yeah
exactly what are you trying to do to me
in my reputation exactly
so then he ended up dropping the kid off
what would the people think
they would call me a pedophile i'm a car
thief don't get the wrong idea i know
yeah so he dropped off the kid scolded
the mom
and still stole the car that's hilarious
they're still taking the car i'm taking
the car hilarious exactly
like took the kid out i was like here's
your kid don't ever do that again
peace out yeah and just booked it with
the suv
so they still haven't found oh wait
sorry and the cop still hasn't came
you had all that time to [ __ ] go back
scold the bomb drop off the kid take the
car
and the cops finally showed up 30
minutes later
i know right like how come they took so
long
but but yeah so initially they had
reported that the car was still missing
but
they updated the article and said that
it was found so they did find the suv
but the thief still remains at large i
like when they get away i do
i like that when they get away for for
non-violent crimes
he was probably like man this car is
tainted now with irresponsibility i
can't [ __ ] i can't look at it
no i'm taking it right to the scrap yard
yeah i gotta ditch this [ __ ] it's
tainted
i know i'm taking it to the docks and
i'm selling it from for cash
but yeah so the mom said that she was
just she only
stopped at this grocery store and was
intending to just spend like a moment
there was that and she was only like 15
feet away from the car
oh swim that's when the theft like
happened so she kept the car running
with the
yeah with the key right yeah is there
any state though that's like safe enough
to do that
or you just all across the board not
supposed to was there any what
like state that's safe enough to do that
you know like different states like
alaska
like you know hawaii no one locks the
front door right because it's just like
aloha everywhere
so like is there a state where like i
don't know it's like
it's so chill everyone does it but
they're from the outside if you don't
live in that culture you don't
understand
well i think that there's a difference
between like leaving your [ __ ] unlocked
at a grocery store parking lot and like
your home because like
my um in-laws they live in a
neighborhood where nobody locks the
doors at all
like ever basically a lot of houses like
that i think the main thing
is leaving your kid in the back seat so
i was wondering if that's okay
in certain states i i do know that
states have different
ages where it's it can become okay
for the kid to be left in the car alone
i thought it was just bad because it's
hot
because some states you can still ride
in the back of a truck still do they
know what temperature
is okay for kids to handle inside the
vehicle yeah i think that's
what i'm more concerned about because
like you're not supposed to leave dogs
or anyone in the car
i don't know like if this i think for
the for the kids i think it's
leaving them alone like you can't leave
them at home alone so leaving them in
the car alone i think it's the same idea
on the unsupervised part yeah i think
that's what it is because they could
like hurt themselves or
drive the car off a cliff leaving a
running car in a parking lot with a kid
inside
man if that was me at four go-kart time
bro
like i couldn't wait like a dog
the dog is not gonna drive your car
somewhere but a four-year-old might i
don't know
so i googled it and this is just for
california so i don't know about other
states can you leave your kid in the car
i googled at what age can you leave your
child in the car and the answer is six
in california what temperatures can they
withstand
in six you can you can leave a
six-year-old in the car in california
yes i guess old enough for them for you
to explain to them
dude i thought it'd be older too can't
wait till my kid's six and some karen's
yelling at me and i'm like
look up the law [ __ ] yeah it's a
california vehicle
section 15620 she's six [ __ ] her
birthday today [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i was waiting look it up look it up
yeah it also says leaving a child under
the age of six with another child who is
under the age of 12
is also considered in a violation also
like 13 and 4 is cool
so it says in other words a child cannot
be left in a car
unless they are under the supervision of
someone who is at least 12 years old
old enough to babysit yeah huh and 13
is old or 12 is old enough to babysit
that's crazy
yeah you're almost old enough to smoke
yeah that's true
jesus dude this reminds me right now um
because my mom used to leave me in the
car with my
brother all the time like when she ran
into the grocery store or
went to go run her errands whatever i'd
be in the car with my brother and
he was born when i was eight i think
eight or nine and so yeah when he was a
baby
always like i was eight or nine and he
was a baby i'd be left
in the car alone and there was this one
time where it was like
[ __ ] traumatizing it was so scary but
and i think i've told the story before
but um
my parents they were shopping at some
furniture store
and it was already nighttime my mom had
this
97 toyota camry where something was
wrong with her doors where
certain doors wouldn't open especially
in the back
like the back doors wouldn't open and
sometimes the front one
sure it wasn't just child lock no it
wasn't no like my uncle who's a mechanic
had to fix it multiple times like i
don't know
but there was just something wrong with
the the car so i couldn't open
the back the back doors my brother was
sitting
on this side in his car seat and i was
sitting
in the left and i mean right and so
there was this man who and
enters the car oh [ __ ] passenger side
with the hood and i just froze
i was like i wanted to scream and i
couldn't see anything
but he he had a hood and he was just
sitting there and he was like
trying to like i don't know what the
[ __ ] he was doing i don't know if he was
on drugs i don't know if he was
mentally ill but he was like trying to
like hype himself up for something
and i was just like like trying to
scream but i couldn't scream and i was
just hugging my brother
like trying to protect him because i'm
like i don't know what the [ __ ] this
crazy dude's gonna do
and um and then i was just like you
can't
you can't be in here like i was just
trying to like
say those words like you can't be in
here so you got it out of your mouth
yeah finally i i was able to
say something and i said something
around along the lines of that
and and finally this dude he leaves
and saying he didn't say he was just in
there not saying anything
not that i remember he was on drugs yeah
he didn't say he just walked he just
opened the door and got in
yeah he just opened the door guy and he
was like looking at me and my brother
and was like
kind of like moving like this and i
don't know maybe he was about to go on a
blind date and he was just really
nervous so he's trying to find a quiet
place with hyping himself up
and just sit down for a second use a
safe space with comes with some kids
hanging out
yeah i don't know but then the reason
why i brought up the point of me not
being able to get out of the car is
because of
that reason like i was i wanted to get
my brother out and just
but i couldn't because the [ __ ] door
your mom left it unlocked
huh yeah well like i said the car was
[ __ ] up so
once they got back into the car i was
shaking and crying and i was like mom a
man just walked in here and then she was
just like
was he fine no
maybe he could be your future dad no my
stepdad was there
oh they both went oh yeah so my stepdad
and my mom went to go shop at this
furniture furniture it's gotta be agreed
to yeah between the two parties
they're too busy arguing over fabrics
they're inside they have no idea i want
corduroy no
corduroy's out of style like this is not
a comfortable couch baby this is not
comfortable and this whole time there's
a dude in there like
[ __ ] man [ __ ] shut up baby
like damn yeah so then i don't remember
what her exact words were but it was
something like she brushed it off
like it was like you were lying i was
just like [ __ ] lying are you alive
okay
yeah it was more like that it was more
like well you're fine right like
did you die yeah nothing i was just like
what the [ __ ] and then i remember
because we were there for
hours and like i said i remember it
being night time so i'm like so i ended
up having to go pee so i go inside
the furniture store to go pee and then
your brother was there by himself then
no so at that point at that time my mom
was already back at the car
oh and so i was just like please don't
leave me alone like please don't leave
so cause she was about to go back in
like she was just checking on us and she
was about to go in and i was just
begging her like please don't leave so
she didn't leave she checked on you
like a good mother after several hours
no she kept checking in periodically
but yeah so then um i ended up going to
the bathroom and there was a window in
that bathroom
and i felt i can't say for a fact but i
you know that feeling when you feel like
you're being watched
i felt like that dude was at the window
like
watching me i don't know it could just
be like childhood just paired with
paranoid because
because of what just happened yeah so
why was there a window in the bathroom
that
outside people can just peek their head
in i don't know but that was [ __ ]
weird that's a weird layout for a
bathroom
right but for a pervert he's like hey
know
i found the goal right yeah so then
every time i hear about
stories like this or whatever or like
you know kids getting taken
by car theft i'm just like never leave
your kids
yeah i mean i don't know why but people
that are drugged out love to try to see
if cars are open
that should happen to me right in front
of barbell oh [ __ ] something just
happened this past week
at our neighborhood too there was this
guy that got caught on a security camera
in our neighborhood
that literally opened uh broke the glass
of
of a car and took a bag from inside the
car
he just broke it like that happens in my
neighborhood every [ __ ] three hours
[Music]
ever since i got one of those like
camera things yeah it lets you know
what's going on in the neighborhood that
happens like literally everything like
the neighborhood app you guys have like
a facebook neighborhood thing where you
kind of catch
i don't have that i have like an app
that tells me everything but if you have
any ring device you're part of like the
neighborhood apps
some conflict the news did say because
of like all the quarantine stuff
like burglaries and stuff like that are
have increased like crazy
yeah isn't that harder because that
wasn't that hard that bites everybody
but everyone's home yeah how they
burglarizing if you're at home
i can't believe how many people leave
tools in their car by the way [ __ ] bro
there's tools getting stolen every
[ __ ] minute in america i think
from people's cars well the case with my
neighbor
he was home and he actually chased this
dude away
so this guy he came into he came into
the neighborhood on a bike
and then so he saw that the guy was like
peeking in other cars
and so then my neighbor gets out and
starts like chasing him like yelling at
him with
with a bat or something i forgot what it
was and so the dude left his bike so
that my neighbor took his
legs like he called the police he stole
my mind man
but then the balls on this dude he came
back
broke the window took the bag and then
ran
so he came back again for another thing
well he lost his bike
to get the thing like to get the bag or
whatever bike was probably more
expensive for sure
what kind of bike what kind of bag was
it a fanny pack i don't even know
hopefully it wasn't lv
[Music]
you